hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello okay
Simza left go hey how you doing how you
feel how you livin how you moving what
uh it is good to be back Hall of Fame
was this weekend yeah we had our first
preseason game and a lot of them are
kicking off this Thursday which that to
me is what I've begin to realize just
how hard the job can be yeah to keep up
with the games you're gonna try and
watch yes
I mean first preseason game I'm not
necessarily worried about evaluating the
Aaron Rodgers of the world go know see
if Aaron can still throw a little bit
like me I make a list of all the rookies
and I go who are the end of maybe the
new free agent Act Lee when I go let me
just watch a few and then once they get
off the field okay now I can move I'm
not gonna check out the third stringers
like I'm just no no I hear you wait for
those guys to get flushed up right or
some of those third stringers end up
putting up great statistics or they pop
to me on film they let me look at them a
little harder here like a cream hunt
laughs yeah exactly right those kind of
guys always pop up but yeah that's the
way I approach the Hall of Fame watching
that film game the other day I just
wanted to see few rookies really I mean
we know who I wanted to see I want to
see Lamar just stop right there yeah but
first I think I think rg3 kind of and
we're gonna get to the Hall of Famers
let me just give a rundown this new
O'Dell
contract thing with the Giants were
definitely getting to yes we are a trade
of Corey Coleman Earl Thomas Kelvin
Benjamin with some comments and then I
got some whoa big training camps Blake
bortles a Kyle Shanahan some fans and
then a rare occurrence on the pot Josh
vendrick during our model photo shoot
did an interview with Drew Brees and
we're just gonna let we just let him go
just let him do it
where's call a stupid so Josh vendrick
finally earning his keep around here I'm
true do you put your workouts in a
spreadsheet when you threw for 5,000
yards did you categorize each completion
from biggest to smallest did you go from
A to Z or Z to a yes so we have a rare
Josh vendrick interview with Drew Brees
the evening drew so all that's coming to
that's gonna be coming up at the end of
the show
but Hall of Fame Hall of Fame Game rg3
looked pretty impressive I think he was
the star of the show for me that was the
decisions out of his hand right accurate
passes right and you know I'm into
little things too like you know watching
the ball come out of his hands did it
pop out of his hands like we pretty good
they show replays right and you go let
me see how it's spinning let me see the
spiral yes his spirals are perfect
I mean his interception certainly wasn't
his fault we have shot it documented
we're not the biggest fans Oh Joe I am
NOT an rg3 fan but I'm not gonna sit
here and hate on anything I see on the
football field and what I saw on the
football field was a good start and a
guy that's yeah putting himself in
position not only to continue his career
but really solidify himself as a backup
if he can continue along this I went oh
so that's what Marty morning wig studied
this offseason the entire Eagles
playbook like it just it felt like that
offense that he was trying to run yeah
yeah
Lamar yeah Lamar's a rookie he's very
much a rookie right he man that he
wanted to run yes did you think he was
as fast as you thought it would be well
to me was he going full speed this is
what everybody has said everybody did
this is so did you get scared - well no
I get it
I knew those were like going to be some
of the focal points first of all not
even Michael Vick is always just gonna
run away from people like shirted field
I know I know it does but that's where
having other great players on the field
would help out a lot more Jackson break
that down like okay so the first bootleg
of the game
yes playing running back on that play do
you remember
I don't yeah neither there's a defense
they were like damn Lamar's in let's
just watch him so right that's what they
did and he faked to the right and the
Liberty linebacker basically just said I
don't think he's gonna give it to him
they're gonna give it to Lamar boot out
and he ran out there with them go with
the fake think about that when you don't
have any greatness on the field truly
about the eyes are on you right like
there was no right there's no Marshall
yonder and Ronnie Stanley but they were
going to him they're plugging us down
the hill run game 5 plays in a row I got
to worry about this all wait Lamar is on
the edge and now we got two steps I mean
now he looked really fast cuz I can't
catch him
random question yes is there
any benefit for the Ravens to let Lamar
keep the bootleg every single time this
preseason because they know all the
attentions gonna be on him and then when
they use him in the game he's strictly a
distraction actually it's yes I would I
mean they're gonna play that together
certainly yes they're gonna stress the
backside of the defense or an over
aggressive side safety or linebacker
certainly you're all over that I thought
he threw the ball well threw the ball
thought it came out of him quick
yes I thought I thought the touchdown
you know it was a simple read yeah but I
thought he threw it pretty well he did I
think the thing I looked at it is just
comfort throwing the ball he changed his
arm angle a few times right where he
went sighs a little bit of all he showed
the ability to get the bot of his hand
quickly moved in the pocket once or
twice and made some throws to his right
like a crow route on the run that was
that was money and those are the things
where he's gonna be great because any
time he escapes the pocket passing lanes
are gonna become wide open because
linebackers are gonna just be more
worried about him running than anything
yes and they're gonna bandage their
coverage responsibilities and all sudden
there's me a gaping hole but yeah for
the most part I would say this too just
as the synopsis of all of it was it
perfect no it was better than the stats
would would claim it would be right he
was let's see four for ten let me just
I'll say this from this standpoint the
Bears defense played some coverages that
I promise you he's never seen a whole
lot in his life and are pretty advanced
for a Hall of Fame preseason game number
one was it really what kind of plan some
like three match and doing some very
creative zone coverages where they were
passing people it's just like a base to
usually get covered too or it's
man-to-man and then it's just that's it
so there was a few times where he
dropped back to pass and I know
everybody wanted like people to be open
and so if there was nobody open like
Baltimore called some pretty you know
basic offensive schematically pass plays
and the Bears defense was all over it
Vic Fangio right so they had a we had a
scramble or you had a throw or he ended
up taking a sack either way there was
some left tackle issues in there when he
was in but for the most part yeah I
think you said it there was things I
liked there was one thing that scared me
and that was his second pass it was the
first third down he had when he
scrambled to the left no one open
man he almost hurt his left knee in his
first run of that guy that came out of
nowhere
yes and he was a linebacker or something
like that something like that all I know
is he came and he came right at the side
of Lamar and I audibly yelled in my
apartment yeah well I was like he's
gonna be out for the game because
because it was that close and I want to
get to it I want to just show you it
real quick so you can vouch for it no I
watched it live okay yeah no it was very
close I went he was very close to losing
his left knee for the whole year
I mean he's leg went straight it buckled
yeah luckily it slid and didn't get
caught and that's like don't like
Leonard fournette
exactly the same things I hate and Hurst
anybody jump out to you hane Hurst you
know good
yeah it looks smart I thought he was
gonna be yeah he's condensed and
muscular the thing I looked you know he
ran one route like a deep cross too with
Lamar in and the game at one point ran a
horrible route like so there's another
instance of like there's a young guy
learning people are gonna look at Lamar
go oh he missed that guy I want to go no
it was a horrible route there was nobody
open and Lamar had to kind of put it
only in one spot where Hayden hurts kind
of made a big catch so all that the
interception yeah
again those aren't interceptions that I
get concerned with and I go oh he really
made a bad reader millions ELLs
interceptions were scared to you
definitely I mean Lamar to me I will
I'll get to it the second but Lamar's
was oh you have you have man to man you
throw to this guy on the back side of
the play he just was a little late doing
it and also had a bad route by a
receiver as well it was a very lazy
around he's it was it was a comeback
with no coming back no exactly you just
kind of stopped he was a little stop
route and Lamar was a little late and
throwing it out there he was a little
lazy with his footwork so both of those
can by that I'm just self scouting I
don't want to be too much of a Lamar
Jackson apologist early on but I also
think people are judging preseason Hall
of Fame week one a little hard but you
know you realize you're not seeing any
of these guys at their top peak right
now like how many guys did you see in
the open field like stumble over their
own feet and like because they all have
camp legs right now their legs like em
play we've been in camp for 17 straight
days and my legs are jello as hell and I
go out there every day and feel like man
I used to run for four but I feel like I
run for
right now because I'm just exhausted and
you're not quite into that shape yet
Johnny Manziel four interceptions were
they were they deflections were they bad
how was it in your mind well I mean the
one where he scrambles in the pocket and
tries to flip it to the guy that was on
his fall
that's the guy that was a nice little
play escape the other ones are his fault
fully through that first interception
you you texted me and were like this is
awful like this is beyond bad that was
like because again I don't want to
criticize him too harshly he hasn't
played football a lot team stinks and
they do stink so we do have to take that
and do it account yes but he threw a pic
that was either gonna be intercepted by
one linebacker intercepted by the other
linebacker where his wide receiver was
gonna get a get killed by the safety
exactly right so that would that play
right there in itself was not only a bad
read it was a bad throw and it was in
too close quarters like I don't know
what he saw there and the the end it all
really with Johnny Manziel the thing
that I'm concerned with about the most
it's just the way the athlete looked I'm
not gonna over value all I care about
with priests exactly right and
apparently Canadian yes well it's you
know I just want to see him and what it
looks like and the twitchiness that we
knew him to have back in the day no
that's not quite there and the way the
ball came out of his hand
it would lack of velocity and lack of
spiral those things concern me and I'm
not gonna say oh I'm done with it or
I've made up my mind but that was not a
impressive start to me to go ooh yeah he
might be the guy we saw in another few
weeks when he's like right now I
question whether he can ever be that guy
again I do I question it and like I told
you I'm just between the stories of him
practicing at the was that the a AFL is
that uh-huh that one yes what was the
one where is that the AFL which way I
got all the damn leagues confused now
Cameron whatever League he went in
practice I know from NFL people that it
was underwhelming his practices and yeah
there between when I got to be there for
two years and there's rumors that he's a
cigarette smoker that's where that's
those two things well in the scare me
players the NFL do you think smoke
cigarettes like almost none I mean like
Jay Cutler was the only guy I knew of in
the NFL that smoked cigarettes the only
guy I mean I'd never played with anybody
that I knew I mean
like listen did I have guys on the team
that were like drunk idiots on a
Thursday night yeah that might have
smoked a cigarette
you're sure actually buying that guys
buying packs right it is like this is
part of its not a single one
not one so for Johnny Manziel Tori
reportedly doing that it's kind of an
outlier I mean it almost is like to me
is like you might as well hold up a sign
of gun I'm not really that serious about
this athletic thing I mean kind of kind
of serious hot take cigarettes are
better for your edification
that's my new out of left go field I
just got an alert Giants ready to pay up
for Odell negotiated make Odell NFL's
highest-paid wide receiver possibly
before the start of the regular season
contradicting yeah that that's from
Rappaport and that's coming out after
what suggesting an Angelina Anderson
reported that the no deal in place
Odell's agent is no longer in town both
sides working to consummate a deal the
understanding is that Odell was being
offered less than Sammy Watkins less
than 16 million a year random Bach ins
was coming to America I just went
through my head we're crazy to realize I
don't remember the guys that also got
paid less than Sammy Watkins Evans
Landry Hopkins cooks Robinson digs Adams
all are getting paid less per year than
Sammy Watkins which is why he's
mentioned a lot yes what do you think
that let's do Odell before the Hall of
Fame just cuz that kind of popped up
right when you heard that story the less
than 16 million a year I that visit that
like physically upset me yeah me too I
was like oh my gosh
I mean you I didn't know they were that
far apart I was yeah I mean we think
they need to be in the Antonio Brown
Seventeen's I mean I I don't that's yes
at least at least I'm you know yes I'm
sorry I don't know what other way to say
he's better than Antonio Brown everybody
I'm sorry and I'm telling you most
people in football think that too and
that's not a disrespect to any o Brown
and he's younger and he's faster and
he's a little bit bigger he's every bit
as good a route runner he said a less
creative offense and a lesser
quarterback to be to surround him but
either way yeah when I first heard that
I was with
I was like in no wait I was like are you
kidding me now that qu was sitting here
was like he's a Giants fan
he was like oh no because throughout
this entire Odell contract experience we
haven't really heard numbers and John
Mara has been playing it perfect we're
gonna handle it we're gonna handle it
we're gonna handle it odhh else played
it perfect I'm showing up I'm posting
things to my Instagram I'm showing you
that I'm working out and then as this is
the really the first time that we've
heard a disagreement in numbers yeah and
it's the phrase they're valuing him less
than Sammy Watkins it's putting a face
to the number right it's not we're
offering him 16 million we're offering
him 15 million in which you go man I
would do a lot of stuff 15 million right
but anyone can say he's better than
Sammy Watkins no doubt I don't know how
you couldn't say he's better than
everybody I can understand some people
go no I think Antonio's better or
Julio's better I could understand that
other than that I really can't
understand the take on you think he's
better than a no Beckham jr. yes and to
hear that like Joe Cena Anderson that
I'm sure that's real she always has the
scoop I can trust you that she seems to
be the player's reporter that's what I
mean so I wouldn't be shocked if maybe
that was the giants like initial offer
and somebody in Odell's camp let that
out to Joe Cena they're gonna time in
and what's really funny Giants saw that
and they're like man that doesn't look
good that doesn't look good on us I'm
gonna take you guys behind the curtain
right okay I started doing this with
shefter earlier look at which reporters
report which news Joe Xena Anderson is a
player reporter so if it's coming from
the camp and fluffy on bail needs to say
something I bet you it's coming through
Josie right right Rappaport
because he's NFL media this is owners
this is franchises GM's all over get
them into Carolina early I mean you're
getting into the giant sauce yes he has
a connection there with maybe the get'em
gentleman or somebody in the giant yes
so don't just look at news as fact look
at news is a representation from the
camp they're reporting from so in the in
one corner in the end Odell corner we
have Joe Xena Anderson trying to get
them to give him more money right in the
blue corner we have Rappaport trying to
go we're gonna take care of them
it's just funny and and I really think
it's it's important to kind of remember
these things so that the next time
Rapoport comes out with O'Dell news it's
coming from the organization like it's
just good to scope your news like that I
agree that's how you read between the
lines the reason we're able to go o Fox
News it's coming from one place CNN it's
coming from another place NFL's just
like that it is exactly right like that
and yes I would imagine that that's kind
of when went down that story got out
there Ian Rapoport probably inquired to
go men I you know is this story true
with whoever he knows of the giants the
giants were probably already in the
midst of having conversations going that
doesn't look good that's gonna piss off
people in our locker room that's gonna
piss off our fan base because they're
gonna go what you're not gonna pay him
as much of Sammy Watkins remember when
you told me that they were and could
include Sammy Watkins I'm telling you
man I know it's because it's more
visceral yeah I was trying to explain
this like I think what agents need to do
when they're holding out it always
becomes player versus franchise it needs
to be player versus G Odell versus
Gettleman right not Odell versus the
Giants yeah my grandma didn't scream and
cheer for Gettleman she screamed and
cheered for the Giant no but the teams
are smart and they make it verse the
team they do because people are loyal to
the emblem on the helmet and I'm saying
Redoute deduce the helmet yeah or put it
to another comp that everyone knows
you're gonna be better than right do you
think he ends up getting more than Sammy
Watkins I do yes I think he's gonna get
paid more than anybody I don't think
there's any way they can deny this
I really don't and I don't think Odell's
at a point to where he knows his worth I
think some of the comments players have
made around the league about Odell
Beckham jr. this year have all
solidified the fact of how high he's
looked upon I mean how many defensive
players and other receivers have we
heard this year ago he's the man he's
the best blah blah blah so I do think
it's gonna happen because I think the
Giants think that there are a serious
Super Bowl contender in the NFC and I
think they know that if this continues
to dance on and continue to be a topic
of conversation that it's going to be a
distraction at some point I'm kind of I
just got a little upset what because I
want to know if Ian Rapoport was one of
the first to report that Odell Beckham
substance video oh because I'm thinking
about what we were just talking about
and that means that it may have come
from the team yeah just kind of thinking
out loud it's fine thank y'all I know
what I mean like I I think that we're in
a world of everyone follows their own
things and they have their own streams
and your news isn't the same as my news
but there's ways awfully kind of
infiltrating it to get your message
apart yeah I'm just kind of thinking
that yeah let's talk about the Hall of
Fame
yeah overall what did you think of the
class and their performances oh it was
great
okay Lee was I I enjoyed it I mean is it
a little long the whole thing definitely
I mean damn it's long what about do you
think that t/o got his own time to shine
no tio tio I I will say yes
tio [ __ ] up that's what I came away
after Saturday gone because I didn't
really want to watch the Tennessee
Chattanooga thing I watched if it wasn't
anywhere to watch it and it's not cool
it just wasn't had lacked lacked any
energy spectacle nothing about it then
when I walked him away from Woodall
Saturday night I said man the Hall of
Fame would have been amazing if Theo had
this speech in between a Dawkins and a
Ray Lewis right and called out the Hall
of Fame there to their faces about their
process would have been would have been
a way bigger platform to what he said in
Chattanooga which nobody cares about he
controlled the afternoon the afternoon
cycle yeah with some tweets and some
posted videos but what people don't
realize is that was going to get
cannibalized by the night time right and
it he was forgotten very quickly yes he
was and yeah I think that he trying to
prove a point
yeah and I'm second-guessing this
because I thought he was kind of I
thought it was cool that he was doing
this so I'm not like trying to say his
main message was this is for you
right and then when he talked about the
Hall of Fame he blamed the writers for
not upholding the tenets of the rifles
yeah I just wish he would have said that
on ESPN during the whole Hall of Fame
enshrinement I think of it as a hit hard
hit home harder did it or the fact that
he controlled the news narrative for six
weeks
every hall-of-famer was talking about
him for six weeks yeah he kind of owned
the whole cycle leading up to it he did
it just really depends what his goal was
yeah you're right I mean now because
I'll be honest you know what he was I
think he did the right move because if
he had to follow Brian Dawkins it would
have been just like what happened to
Randy Moss am I the only one that think
that brandy mosses speech seemed really
lackluster after Brian Dawkins well
Brian Dawkins had the best speech of the
night I mean I know it was all off the
top of the head well I'm yeah I mean
Brian Dawkins is just an impressive
human being and it was so natural and
emotion based and yeah it was just easy
for him it wasn't too scripted
yes that's hard to follow up that I mean
he's amazing he's an amazing talker he's
got a great life story and yet mosses is
that's tough to live up to Moss isn't
that kind of guy to be like that
children for me it was I'll just be
honest i sat there and I was I was
celebrating with Brian Dawkins I had a
shot poured for the end of a speech
right if I were to tell you that I'd
cried that's like it under I almost
cried like nine times and the times when
you almost I did I mean every time they
showed the family's mom or the kids like
I would know I'm the worst man so really
yes you're just a sad I mean my little
daughter she just watches me and she's
just like are you crying okay but but I
thought brought the this is me and and
look everyone's life is unique and
everyone life is different
Brian Dawkins getting up there and
talking about how he almost committed
suicide and talking about being the
lowest of the low and every great thing
he's had he had to undo it endure pain
to get there yeah every speech is in
essence the same I went through hard
times I didn't get here by myself these
people helped me I did it a little bit
of shot to the haters and now I mean
like every story's kind of the same but
Dawkins I felt like hit all of the peaks
so much harder yeah that to hear Randy
Moss come afterwards be like I went
through some stuff I was like Brian
Dawkins almost killed himself yeah so it
was it was weird like I thought Randy
Moss is afterwards like obviously I love
Randy I thought what Randy did with his
tie
honoring so many of the victims that
that were innocent at the hands of
police officers right I thought that was
a great way to talk about it yeah that
was amazing
4:30 meet me at the town center that was
out so amazing and then Bill Belichick
of course of was showing up in khakis
and thong sandals yeah well that's what
he wears every day to the office this
time of the year but to me you're gonna
be onstage at the Pro Football Hall of
Fame
yes can I get like a Johnson and Murphy
negative now give a damn him and Rob
flew the private plane there and they
showed up and did that paid homage to
the Randy Moss and that was it so our
man Nana hit me up on the Instagram Rams
and he said when Bela check gets
inducted I'm gonna be so pissed if they
don't make him a gold hoodie and then
halfway through the speech he cuts the
sleeves off with Brady going wild and
throwing avocado ice I mean it's the
gold the hoodie thing I mean hoodies
with snow sleeves is in style now and
that's because of Bill Belichick not
crazy I do see a lot of athletes that
kind of they like the hood but they do I
am a hoodie with no sleeves made it
looks like the highlights right here
delete your important I stole it they
had a box of coyotes I said them they're
cool I'm taking one I stole it up hoodie
Omar Omar Omar deal with it yeah I mean
what would I want to say here I wanted
to go over just last thing like would
the Hall of Fame thing I mean tio has
every right to be pissed off yes
I mean he had he was a first-ballot
almost a hundred more receptions than
Randy Moss and 700 yards more receiving
and only three less touchdowns and he
for some reason was on the third ballot
and Randy Moss was on the first one yeah
and now the NFL's talking about oh you
know you might have to sign a contract
to say you're definitely gonna be there
you know come on that's what they talked
about the rate versus yeah first of all
it just just vote on people to get in
the damn Hall of Fame stop with these
all side storylines and this has
happened one time well here's what I
think it is so let's relax I heard Chris
Carter talking about this on first
things first and he was talking about
how it's the last big speech that you're
ever going to give it's the last time or
you're gonna be real
showered with this much adoration if I
told you that like I think about like
this all these old guys when their
career is over right this is the one
date on their calendar that they look at
their family they go don't tell me what
we're doing in August that first weekend
you know where I'll be because it's the
same thing every year yeah they get
around their guys they're a legend again
and it's this amazing feeling and it's
probably a little bit when a 21 year old
comes to me and they go man I love going
out to the clubs and I look him and go
nothing good happens at a club I know
it's fun you're just wasting your money
you're not gonna find the woman of your
dreams there and they're looking at me
going man don't tell me how to live my
life you loser right is square these all
these old Hall of Famers know that in
the end those moments that weekend is
really the only thing that matters yeah
and tío doing this they're going in 20
years 30 years you're gonna realize that
you wanted to despair with us because in
the end were the only ones that know
what this is like yeah so I think
they're coming at it from this pure like
purity like and they're in and once
they're in you kind of forget about it
tío just goes I've spent my entire
career bidding [ __ ] on yeah and I'm not
ready to give it up by some of you too I
mean some of those people in the hall
this is other boaters so that's the
other problem people are forgetting that
that some of these like Chris Carter's
and them have personally attacked him
over the years
we also he also played in the first era
where there was a lot of not just like
local news reporters but like ESPN
debate shows you know that like those
didn't exist for Jordan no you know like
LeBrons experience Square to Jordans
experience is different
Tio's experience like imaginary Bruce
Carter got kicked off for doing exactly
right
yes yeah I know you're right it made a
totally different story be totally of
life totally instead of pure like
pressure that you have to deal with
because of the public spirits on you
yeah back then going to Minnesota was
like don't worry no one's gonna bother
you in Minnesota now it's like no man
it's all - matter where you go yes all
right last thing that bothers me about
the Hall of Fame dude one quick thing
yeah I thought the only time I got
embarrassed to swim in the Eagles fans
boo
I'll check balichek yeah and Robert
Kraft looked at him and he's like are
you kidding me
but then I saw Emmitt Smith and Michael
Irvin up there and apparently they booed
Emmitt and there was one clip where Eman
was like wouldn't stop talking to Ervin
and after our experience with lambreaux
I was like dude an M it is definitely
pissed as [ __ ] about Eagles fans Emmitt
Smith has a true hatred for Eagles fans
and it's really on some glad the Eagles
fans booed everybody that's what they do
just stay with what they do did deal
with it you like that I mean that's what
I'm gonna take that that's what you guys
do it it's not it's out of love for the
Eagles and hate of everybody just feel
like Eagles fans are always the cousin
at the wedding that has too much and
then like during a speech stands up it's
like yeah I hear ya but so I embarrass
but they're also amazing they're also
like the only one that's allowed and
that's like real in the building too I
would say they're Eagles fans were so
real that Brian Dawkins forgot to thank
the Denver Broncos like he did he had to
apologize later but he said he's like no
let's talk about the Eagles fans like I
stood up at my house yeah I know all
right so what was the other thing about
the Hall of Fame that you want to get
off your chest that you didn't like oh
I'm it's not actually about the olive a
Luis didn't look like his bust but that
was horrible it was the worst bust I
ever saw like we should his family's got
a call and be like that's not even
that's horrible
Randy Moss had the best bust of the
night yeah Hopkins was okay the weird
thing is is I thought about this you've
never not only have you not seen Dawkins
hair yeah because he always wore a cat
right but also like I felt like his bust
needed a visor you know what I mean like
that's his identity I was a black was
this yeah a black visor yeah it is scary
look right so I'm cutting you off no
it's not you're good but I get annoyed
with the social media stuff with Ray
Lewis I'm so sick of people calling him
a murderer and everything I can't take
it I really can't and I think it's so
[ __ ] wrong so this isn't this is
Simms Simms will look at a tweet and
then he'll go down and look at some of
the comments and you know you're doing
this because every time someone said Ray
Lewis says that he kisses his kids in
the mouth so and be like just like he
killed people
exactly
like I just it's so ridiculous let me
just tell you this is the story I know
from the homies from everybody this is
the story that was always told in the
locker room Ray Lewis didn't kill
anybody okay everybody back off that
stupid thing
oh yeah the Atlanta Police Department
didn't want to didn't want to accuse a
famous black football player of murder
and they just let him go somehow the
jury just let him go okay yeah right
okay
the story is this somebody got killed in
the strip club that night most people
know who the guy was right from
everything I've known from urban legends
or whatever from the people in the
locker room this guy stabs somebody
outside the elena strip club that night
and from everything I know is Ray Lewis
witnessed it along with other people and
Ray Lewis just basically didn't wrap the
guy out and they basically said no we
know you were there and you know who it
was right you need to tell us and he
said no and they basically done since it
all right well then we're gonna charge
struction of Jeff's right we're gonna
charge you and go through this but from
everything I know and maybe I'm wrong
again I don't know but this is a story
what you're hearing there's always heard
this this is I've known this from back
in the day is that this guy that did the
stabbing was a stone-cold gangster from
South Florida and he told Ray Lewis have
you rat me out I'm gonna kill your
family and everything that's always been
the story mmm they're everything so then
Roy ray just basically had a bite the
bullet didn't wrap the guy out went
through the whole jury but that's always
been the story through NFL locker rooms
from the second I got in the NFL how
often is it talked about the NFL locker
I mean it was it was like every time you
play the Ravens with somebody like hope
he doesn't kill you as always yeah I'll
play that murderous linebacker today
some teammates would go there stories
would come out right you start going oh
this is no that's not what happened buh
buh buh buh somebody would know somebody
from South Florida or somebody that
played with Ray before or whatever it
was so every time you play the Ravens it
became like a discussion almost like
comments about that definitely always
yes and it bothers me and Ray's not a
murderer or a murderer in any capacity
he'd kick your ass on the field but he's
a pretty damn good guy off of it yeah
do you kiss your son on the mouth you
know I do a little from time to time do
you ever kiss your dad on the mouth no
never never happen my I mean my dad only
he first time he told me I love me he
loved me I was like 32 so of like a
handshake hug type uh yeah with this Tom
Brady Ray Lewis like there's like this
generation of mouth kissing dads that
I'm not ya know it's do I have to do
that now you don't I let you want to do
it sometimes it's not even like it just
happens at times where I like I'm
kissing his cheeks wrong and then I
might like get the edge of his lip or
whatever something like that but you
know he's seven yeah and he's always
gonna be seven to me I think that's what
happens is he's gonna be 27 I'm still
gonna see this 7 year old I'm gonna kiss
you on the cheeks and do all this [ __ ]
that I used to do with you it doesn't
change I'm sure I thought that my kids
laughed at that part you know yeah macho
teenagers or college kids no he doesn't
do that because you know they're getting
roasted at school today alright so a
bunch of news the Patriots just cut
Malcolm Mitchell Wow yeah yeah while
they were trying to trade them that
makes sense yes so they're scared of
them right Browns trade Corey Coleman to
the bills for a seventh round pick in
essence a throw away for a former
first-round pick and all of a sudden
Josh Gordon's not at Camp some people
are saying it's because he doesn't want
to be on Hard Knocks Corey Coleman's now
gone and Jarvis Landry is the only one
left of the trio that he said is maybe
the or he said is the best why receiving
core the NFL and I want an apology for
him from one of those crying emojis he
said to that so when you said that
Cleveland wasn't a top 5 receiving trio
and then he wrote crying emojis you'd
like Jarvis Landry to an issue in Apollo
I want the yellow circle thinking
thinking face that says I'm sorry Chris
Simms you're pretty good the thinking
face does not mean that thinking faces
when somebody like tweets or text
something that's questionable yeah
you're kind of like yeah you're you
would need like V like the prayer hands
maybe or like a face down
yes like here right I'm sorry so I look
at the receiving core it's Jarvis Landry
Josh Gordon I think is gonna play yeah
it seems they're sticking to that and
then it's Rashad Rashard Higgins Jeff
Janis and a lot of people are talking
very highly about Antonio Callaway is
that kid from Florida yeah he's super
talented I mean he would have been
probably one of the top 40 players
picked in the draft this year if he
didn't have the off the field that she
was and that was like one of the first
things I thought other they must be
liking what they see out of him okay
that he can do that now I still look at
it and go out it's an unproven roster
yes at wide receiver I know they like
the Higgins kids Jarvis Landry certainly
can do everything and maybe Jeff Jeff
Jeff Janis is performing at all those
years in Green Bay I'm just not gonna I
know I guess Janis he's just like in
Green Bay one of those guys that's a
whoa big offseason guy where he has the
physical tools he can run he can jump
and then something happens in the game
where he drops a lot of balls that's
what I've always read about him in Green
Bay right and we'll see if this is
different but I know do you think you
think it might be an Antonio Callaway
tie I would think that he'd be the guy
there and yeah I think that it showed me
that they probably have confidence that
Josh Gordon will be back at some point
because to lose Ricardo Lewis to I know
that turned into a very shallow position
yes now they do have some decent side
and play and they do have some running
backs that can catch the ball to the
back field through that can make them
well forget it we always like okay so I
forgot to bring this up last episode
Duke Johnson has been going to Hugh
Jackson and saying play me at wide
receiver right like he's trying to be a
position change yeah I was going out of
left go field and going this is about
running backs not getting a lot of money
he's a playmaker Bowa
he genuinely wants to be wide receiver
he actually wants to play defense but he
will take wide receiver was the article
that I read about that's I didn't know
that about the defensive side but yeah I
guess you got I guess we do count Duke
Johnson as a wide receiver I mean I so
then it's it's Landry Gordon Duke
Johnson that's what I mean that's like
when people go to like New England they
don't go England all their receivers or
whatever I go well they got some good
receivers and they got two good tight
ends and yes don't forget James lanes
white caught
11:14 Rex Burkhead who's literally
played a game in the NFL for the bangles
where he has a receiver the whole game
right so we always forget that I me
included I always go oh they're wide
receiver court and then go oh it did
they have those two other pass catchers
then yeah they can line up as a slot
receiver 30 times a game and it really
don't miss a beat look at the Colts oh
they're wide receivers aren't they good
okay but they just signed Ebron so it's
e bran and Jack Doyle right they're
gonna have two tight ends in the field
all the time exactly right yeah it's
position --less offensive football
playmaker type of stuff this is what I
always hate about training camp too
because there there's probably another
guy or two on the wide receiving corps
in in Cleveland who's doing really well
that's gave them the confidence to do
this and we don't know about it so
that's just is what it is
Damien red who Corey Coleman though
that's cool for him I do think he has
potential I mean I always thought he did
he just hasn't been able to stay healthy
he'd he can really go always thought
that coming out of Baylor and I think
it's in a good he's in a good spot I
mean you talk about another team that's
an underwhelming receiving corps oh the
bills I mean yeah okay they got Jeremy
Kerley okay alright yep I mean he's
getting up there at age you know you got
guys like rod Streeter Andre Holmes kind
of like career journeyman who have never
done anything yeah
Zay Jones the second round pick last
year who was a little bit underwhelming
and then you got Kelvin Benjamin who's
been heard a lot through his career and
has always had a bad knee so everybody
gonna depend on him so the other thing I
think about is this yeah what can Josh
Allen do they're all really far no doubt
about who was the receiver that was
gonna outrun there's no monster exactly
right and even the further that point
you because you're exactly right there's
nobody that stresses the defense that
way also I'd go who's really like the
legit jitterbug Julian this is the New
England offense to run him Brian date
balls they all see their know it's a lot
of bigger leap on me so who's gonna be
that guy to do those little jerk I'm
sure everyone's we're at Corey Coleman I
think he'll come in all the reports I'm
seeing about Corey Coleman are maybe
he's just a slot which is like an insult
but in today's NFL I mean being a slot
receiver is also not only is it a great
to have it's such a better value for an
NFL team because when you have a slot
guy you don't have to pay him as my own
because we haven't come to the grips yet
that maybe that's more important the
percentage of passes completed inside is
so much greater than the passes on the
outside but yet we're still trying to
stretch the field yeah where maybe if
offensive coordinators ran more dynamic
play calls with motions and cleared out
space and had levels concepts all the
time but no we're still no we got to
spread them out further you don't have
to spread them out further not at all I
mean look at the Patriots pop pass
exactly look at Lena two years ago with
Kyle Shannon what they do they lined up
in the I formation Julio Jones got
really close and they said we're gonna
run it this way that that backside guy
gets too greedy but that's not a slant
right behind you it's like a four foot
throw if anything tell me if I'm wrong
yeah
spreading out if anything helps the
defense might I mean in a you're trying
to defend a bunch and then they all go
to different areas exactly right I think
that's harder than going coming across
no doubt about it you it's there's
there's less you can do when you're
spread out and some of those stationary
positions there's less crosses picks
things like that that you just can't do
with like you're saying with bunches and
stacks and things like that you can have
different releases that confuse people
you can stress people's rules out
different ways so yeah I would think
that's a big part of what they're
missing in that offense there I will
give credit to bean who I believe is the
GM right there yeah they these first two
years have spent zero time waiting with
what they're going to do when they think
they need to make a move they make a
move they've moved up for the
quarterback they got rid of all their
receivers last year remember they got
rid of all their quarterbacks and they
drafted guys Trudeau vyas wait that have
panned out that look really good yeah
and they're just not afraid to pull the
trigger no they have a vision of what's
actually after Doug Whaley where all he
did I feel like he had a gun in a case
and said one day I'll pull that trigger
yeah
but until then let's try it out EJ
Manuel one more time you know what I
mean like I'm happy they have a
direction yes I don't think good this
year no I think like yeah they're one of
the teams I look at they cannot go back
to the playoffs like them the fact that
no one's talking about their offensive
line and the fact they've lost corty
Glenn at left tackle and Erik wood
Center and and incognito and LeSean
McCoy has his issues like I'm just talk
about the offensive line yeah right [ __ ]
all these free agent wide receivers if
your offensive line loses three out of
five and two of the three we're like Pro
Bowlers yeah you're probably gonna take
a step back yes like I look at that look
at the Panthers they lose Noor well then
they just lost one of their attack
Darryl Williams they're gonna take a
step back this year exactly right that's
right Buffalo Carolina and I think the
Kansas City Chiefs have you made me
preach no I'm just saying those are
three teams I don't think we'll be back
in the playoffs like I think the Kansas
City Chiefs are gonna be more exciting
to watch yeah you're gonna need Patrick
mahomes to play out of his mind he's
gonna have to play out of his mind I
still think there's deep issues they are
forgetting all the defensive guys that
are gone from Eric Barry's coming back
from an Achilles right Marcus Peters is
gone right Dee Ford has never been
anything to this point just in Houston's
been very average the last two years I'm
nothing special
yes sir who's that Derrick Johnson's
gone right Ron Parker's gone so you
started to look and you go damn who's
that defense that defense wasn't that
good to begin with so now we got to mix
and match some people we don't even
really know or not household names to
this point so yeah I look at that along
with the fact that the AFC West is
better in general and they are starting
a rookie quarterback to where yeah
Kansas City I think set up a team that
maybe just misses out yeah I like that
speaking of we were talking before just
about oh let's do Kelvin Benjamin why
we're on the subject his comments about
Cam Newton I mean I feel like I would
have been even more successful if I
don't know man looking back on it I
should have just been drafted by
somebody else which is a crazy thing to
say you don't control that Plus you were
a reach if anything like they made you a
first-round pick yeah I should have
never went to Carolina truly I think
they were bad for me if you would have
put me with any other quarterback let's
be real you know what I'm saying
any other accurate quarterback like
Rodgers or Eli or Big Ben anybody
quarterbacks with knowledge that know
how to place a ball and give you a
better chance to catch the ball it just
felt like I wasn't in that position two
things one it shows you that the NFL
still doesn't understand that Eli
Manning hasn't been good for three years
yeah so that's funny right - the team
went 15 and won and went to the Super
Bowl
while you were out for it out of him
that's that's where he's like that's
where I just look at the argument and go
what how can you even make this argument
they were better and the guy won the guy
you're talking about won the MVP when
you didn't play yes and when you did
play they struggled and I'm not it's not
there's really no correlation what they
do you know what the Panthers always did
with Kelvin Benjamin in those sets what
they put them out wide yeah there's no
doubt that were so-so for one I want to
go you know listen I know Cam Newton's
like numbers and everything in the world
aren't always perfect I understand that
but I would also say men Cam Newton's
the way he plays fits Kelvin Benjamin
I mean Kelvin Benjamin somebody show me
yards after catch show me a highly he
only had one highlight in college where
this is my complaint about right he's a
back shoulder jump ball type of thrower
that you split out wide because he can't
run some of the you know change
direction shorter type routes because
he's so big of course those guys always
have trouble then let alone he has a
faulty knee that makes him less able to
cut hard on those shorter change of
direction routes so there's obviously
some type of issue that he had with Cam
Newton I don't know what happened or
where that went but there has to be
something there it's the only thing I
can look at I'm doing the stats are
never gonna be great in that offense
just not the way they are I mean it's
just not the way they played football
yeah I think of anything Kelvin Benjamin
the problem that he has in this league
right now is you need to stack him out
wide cuz since there's no threat of
going deep he's a liability for a
running game yeah because you can cheat
on him all the time and put an extra man
in the box I think that he actually can
kind of stagnate an offense sometimes
because there is no other gear no he is
the opposite of versatile yeah he is one
note go and throw back shoulder or throw
it high pretty much and I think that
that Carolina offense last year after
the trade kind of opened up a little bit
Christian McCaffrey had some more
running lanes their problem was they
just didn't have any other wide
receivers to play those positions but DJ
Moore looks like he could be that guy
yes all the clips I'm seeing looks like
he could be special he can be a
superstar and
and I just worry cuz you like Corey
Coleman - yeah well hey I'm gonna miss
on some that's the way they go and we'll
see
I still hold hope for Corey Coleman
because I do see the explosions still
there and if that's there yes
but man my man djay more I do these
flashing yeah he's a clip he was he was
the closest thing I saw her like a Percy
Harvin coming out in a while so that guy
where he can take a speed sweep and turn
it up and go 70 or he can run by in for
a 70-year bomb or catch a slant route
and make people miss and run for a 70
yard touchdown
Kyle Shanahan our favorite coach in the
NFL had a pretty cool quote we were
talking earlier about bunch formations
you're talk about Kyle's offense and he
says that I really want my players to
overcome coaching and this was the quote
that he said so let me just make sure I
got some audio of my Kentucky player
don't be a robot it's a nice way of
trying to tell a player don't be a robot
you know coach that's what you told me
to do well yeah I drew it on paper
versus cover three and you got cover two
like it's not the exact same you got a
now you got to do this sometimes you got
to overcome coaching I I apologize for
not covering calling it verse the right
coverage but when you don't now you got
to overcome my mistake or that I'm not
as good as you so please help us out
it's just a nicer way to me of saying
hey don't be a robot and and he goes on
to say if you're facing zone there's one
thing like I and he had this great line
where he goes on the whiteboard it's
five yards straight line and then a
45-degree angle he goes but that's not
how it worked no but the thing jammed to
the line of scrimmage and sudden you go
damn I'm a step slow I gotta cut it off
in four yards and then get there exactly
those are things like that but what I
loved about it was I've never heard a
coach say I apologize one and number two
make up for my mistake I've never heard
a coach say that they've made a mistake
before yeah that's the difference and
then this the other thing I thought
about was he's such a former wide
receiver you know like and that and that
I think well that was my a teleph go
field about McVeigh Kyle yeah and Josh
McDaniels is there
all former wide receivers and they all
have the best wide receiver concepts for
offensive coordinators yeah but have you
talked to him about overcoming coaching
before I just never heard a coach say
yeah yeah yeah I definitely have it's
something that's talked about a lot and
I'm gonna get into something a little
New England need to they're about that
but like yeah first of all that that
jump talked to me - Kyle expects to call
the play against the defense he thinks
you're gonna play I mean that's how
highly he thinks of himself and his
study and he demands that of himself to
go no I think they're gonna run this
coverage that's why I called this play
and but if I did he literally puts out
formations to draw a certain type of
coverage yes he knows the tendencies of
exactly right if he's in and he goes oh
I motioned the guy over here then they
go to this coverage and he's all over
that's why he is great at what he's done
chest it is he's playing chess yes you
have to be able to adjust on the fly and
I think the other point where I was
gonna go with there is just hatred II ya
the Patriot like knowing this has always
jumped out to me about Belichick and
even my time of McDaniels they didn't
want the coaches to over coach
especially on the field right like Oh
things are messed up let's not stop
practice because the secondary is
talking to themselves and they can't
figure out the call no let them [ __ ] up
the call and we'll teach them when we
watch it in the meeting room they gotta
learn to fix these things on the fly
just like so there's not being a robot
it was my point otherwise you can't
coach them during the game like that you
be crazy is how many times my career
teams go blow the whistle stop it let's
make sure we get all on the same page no
these are teaching moments right so it's
not if I always tell you the right
answer you'll never learn why you're
wrong exactly and Bill would that's
where I always took away from New
England to build me practice hard
like I would Jon Gruden the offense was
scripted to look good every day ah our
quarterback completed nine out of every
ten passes and you know the offense
looked great and I called plays that
were great and but yet he also told the
defense to be in certain coverages for
those plays that's what they would do
and be used to try to Derrick Brooks
crazy oh here we go scripting for
success we would never apply those
coverage against this formation he used
to yell this [ __ ] like that and I'd be
like damn okay well
why are we calling this play but John
Wanda work it whatever yeah these rhymes
or his reasons but the one thing I
always took away from New England is no
we're not here to like make everybody
feel warm and cozy every day after
Friday tional football are going through
struggles for a certain period of
practice it's gonna happen during the
quarter of a game yeah you know we
played great the first and second
quarter the third quarter we laid an egg
and then we had to regather ourselves to
come out and play strong in the fourth
and it's crazy how little things like
that she's I know you see I started
watching last chance you season three
yeah which it gave me so much anxiety I
got through like two and a half episodes
it's like if a bag man at a major
university come to university that while
he was like the assistant d-line coach I
was like he could be the head coach and
it's it's crazy that you know practice
he's just yelling and that first game
they start to just get like absolutely
destroyed and he's looking he's just
gonna figure it out figure it out you
guys gotta figure it out and you guys
you need to figure it out and I'm like
what are you doing like you're the worst
coach of all time but I think about what
you're saying and and how balichek works
with like situational coat like
situational coaching his team is
prepared for every moment right
there's nothing they're not prepared for
except for apparently a pass to the
quarterback Philly Philly Philly Philly
which is amazing but no that's why you
even see like you've seen bill in the
game right he's watching the game
something happens and he just he picks
up his little notepad and he goes yes
right because like Jabbar react yelling
at the players at that point after a
week of preparation and letting them
know they just you know [ __ ] up a
60-yard ey oh they they already know
they did they're already beating
themselves up balichek's not gonna go
over there and go hey idiot you screwed
that one up really bad I mean you always
know when bills a little panicked the
only time I know when bills a little
pays when he starts to go over to the
defensive bench and he gets on the
whiteboard real quick then I go oh
here's something like truly
schematically that he wants to reinforce
with the players one more time because
he didn't like the way look that's when
I know okay Bill's a little stressed
about something other than that he's
gonna he's trust in his coaching I would
say this to everybody out there to
stress is a very
interesting way to find out who you're
really with so your relationship your
friends all that stuff I'm thinking
about balichek in the way he handles
stress I'd love this story this guy's
name is Walt Bettinger he's a CEO of
Charles Schwab okay when he takes out a
candidate to interview he believes that
the most important thing for any company
is personnel I think you could say that
about football too but when you're the
CEO you're not gonna get time to like
vet these people like interview them a
lot so he gets one chance and he does
the same thing he takes them the
breakfast and he has the restaurant
which he goes to all the time
purposely mess up their order because he
wants to see how they're gonna handle it
are they gonna be you know what it's
fine I'll just eat it's not a big deal
are they gonna do you know who I'm here
with he looks away they handle stress
even that little stress yeah but think
about if you're at a restaurant and they
messed up your food yeah it's gonna make
you feel a certain type of way
especially if you're nervous yeah that's
the way he tests people right and I I
think that the way NFL coaches or NFL
players handle stress you said this on
dan Patrick last week I thought it was
great when you see Aaron Rodgers or Cam
Newton they're smiling they're not
smiling because it's a different game
they're smiling because they're so
prepared and they're so much better than
everybody else that it is easy yeah when
you look at the linebacker and he's
yelling and he's that guy probably isn't
ready
yeah he's stressed he's stressed out and
it's probably not handle it right great
Louis you've always said singing and
dancing and dance and read singing and a
Gerald Bray after the play who I'm
focused he's that stressing no he's not
asking questions not at all Tennessee
Titans playoff game against the Patriots
what were they doing between place
freaking the [ __ ] out remember that yeah
yelling at each other I don't know what
to do what Tom Brady's gonna play I got
you I got you right yeah yeah I mean
look at look at guys in between snaps
and you'll learn a lot about your own
football you're exactly right you will
you'll know where they are and how
secure they are and themselves their own
abilities but yes I mean you said it I
mean yeah Aaron Rodgers isn't out there
like just giggling for nothing he's
giggling because he's like damn business
but
and me a million dollars to go out here
and carve somebody up today and they're
gonna do it again and I'm awesome at it
and nobody can catch me and I can throw
this damn ball through any hole in this
damn City well yeah yeah that's why they
feel like that you know right yeah like
you said right dancing over the ball
never forget that ball they doing a
little shimmy with it and all that's not
all the thinking you were supposed to be
doing now you're just less today no more
I'm looking at my offensive linemen who
were going there looking at him going
damn he's not stressed at all and
they're getting more nervous that's all
right I remember looking at guys like
can yet a walker and John Wade and them
gone like they were like he's crazy huh
[Laughter]
protect me
speaking of titans Cyprien goes down out
for the year they sign Kenny Vaccaro
is that an even swap does it change the
kind of because I always thought Cyprian
was a physical physical yeah and I don't
really see that with Kenny Vaccaro Kenny
is a little bit of a tweener like a
coverage certainly not afraid to throw
his body around you know listen I think
Kenny Vaccaro a little bit better than
the the world and the NFL thinks I think
he was put in some very tough positions
and that Saints defense said I don't
think we're realistic to ask him to do
what he did he had Gruden kind of
eviscerated him one time talking about
the right weather because Sean Payton's
his buddy so he was gonna do that for
Sean but the the other thing too that's
interesting about that whole
conversation is Eric reads better than
Kenny Vaccaro did you hear that
apparently they he the the flight was
messed up and that's why they just signs
Kenny Vaccaro
he was up here you know that which he
was here in Jersey Eric Reid yes and we
did have a lot of thunderstorms this
weekend so when I first saw that I was
like what do you mean are they saying he
canceled out of the fights or were they
and it sounds like it was weather
cancellations right and we did we had
some serious thunderstorms here did so
maybe that's what really happened either
way I don't think Eric green in
Tennessee is a good fit just because I
don't think it's the climate for his
social stands it's going to be
beneficial to him at the end of it if
you're going to get a safety hurt this
is the offseason to do it because
there's so many out there Mike Mitchell
still out there yeah Eric Reid still out
there
and there's a number of other guys that
is the CJ Ward is not like good football
players but I just you know the Titans
routine that I'm high on so I wasn't
sure if it's Byard and Vacarro back
there it seems like it's a little more
free ranging where if it was read and
and buy yeah we could kind of play
inside a little bit more yeah but yeah
it'll be interesting it will be it's not
gonna make me think a whole lot
different in their defense okay sip is
just what you heard you know I think
everybody heard when I was working for
New England he was coming out of was he
far to Atlantic or Florida International
I can't remember it's one of the two but
I was working in New England I know our
area scouts and John Robinson FIU whoo
FIU John Robinson who's the GM there now
love Cyprien I mean loved him love the
guy who's that the guy that Grunk
throughout the club oh I don't think so
no I don't know you're right I'm not
sure it might have been but sifrin's the
guy that knocked out Kelsey in the
wild-card game he can breath remember
right and he you could tell Brian's team
Sergio Brown that's right that's right
oh no Cyprian said on Kelsey was the the
game changing changing when that
happened it completely deduced their
offense and then Mariota caught a pass
to himself and it was going on yeah
speaking of we got to contract things
going on right now Aaron Donald is so
willing to hold out that man Lefko is
looking like a genius on this one that a
lot of players need to report by Tuesday
oh yeah because if you don't report by
Tuesday then you're a restricted free
agent next year instead of an like UFA
yeah that is but Aaron Donnell doesn't
care Aaron Donnell says I'm holding out
yeah this is gonna go forever it could
go I mean for in his case he can do this
right because he talked about he can
come the week he doesn't expanding
doesn't expect to ever be on another
team with the Rams right now he's going
I'm gonna be with the Rams forever so
what his hears about my free agent year
right that's what he's at least hoping
and I think Josh Gordon that's a
different thing right and I was not
aware of this rule which first of all
the first thing I said it was holy crap
the next CBI this has to be changed
because that's stupid I mean are you
kidding me
here we go they already have a
fifth-year option which is stupid to
begin with
now you're telling me they can't hold
out a camp to dispute that fifth-year
option when they are far exceeded the
money and the value of that your option
I mean that's just stupid it's another
like you know the owners got one on the
over on the players again it's just
acting to believe that it's so stupid
but yeah Erin Donald stay stay there all
day men if they don't make you the
highest paid defensive player in
football there's something wrong
the other one is Earl Thomas who pretty
much said in his statements look I took
a deal last time to help out the Legion
of boom because I wanted to stay
together and after I watched Richard
Sherman Terry's Achilles and see them
just cut him like that it's kind of hit
me in the face that I need to take care
of business and if you guys only see me
for one year then trade me to an
organization that sees me for a long
time because I still think I have time
to play yeah Earl ain't going away I
think Earl and Aaron Donald I think
they're both holding out if they don't
get a deal yeah Lee old Mack his camp
has been so quiet that I don't even know
where to put it but Errol Thomas III
think there's a 0% chance he's playing
with the Seahawks next year if they
don't get a deal I I feel that way about
both of those guys I feel I Aaron Donald
the macker in different situations
because they're still on that first deal
so I still have confidence that's going
to get done yes I think they're gonna
hold strong but I do think that the
organization's themselves are gonna go
we see the value in it that's the issue
of Seattle and RL Thomas like what's
what's the value for Seattle tell me
there is none right so see how they're
caught in a tough spot because the value
is not alienating a fan base yeah okay
they've been trying to say this is not a
rebuild mhm if every member the Legion
of boom is gone yeah you can't argue
that anymore it's still Ross do you like
Russell Wilson yeah not as much as the
Legion of boom right so they're they're
messing with legacy they're messing with
fan hood you know they're on the
opposite side yeah we're here's a player
that's fate that's fighting the logo
yeah but he actually means more to them
than the logo yeah you're right he's
right up there with it there's no doubt
because if you think about it what did
our friend Amir always say who's a
Niners fan when we went to Seattle
training camp it was like a year too
after they won the Super Bowl and our
friend Amir would walk down and he'd go
look at all these Fairweather fans like
all the jerseys are still new yeah the
tags are still on these jerseys right
now a lot of those fans and I'm not
questioning Seattle fans oh yeah but the
Legion of boom is what sure did this new
generation Iran to a new level
hurl might mean more to a lot of people
IRLS I mean he's listen he's certainly
one of the most important players in
franchise history I don't think he has
anything to stand on here yeah that's
where I think it's it's different than
the other situations Earl
broke his leg and talked about retiring
Earl was a smaller type of safety as as
is anyways so and he's making ten
million dollars which makes him top six
and football at the safety visit really
top five because kam Chancellor's not
playing I think he just was
multiple-year security which I which I
get that but I just think Seattle is at
the point right now but they're not
gonna do that
how can say I will do that and also like
during a regular season game he goes to
Dallas and says come get me exactly
right so this is where I this is where
they're in a no-win situation they are
and I don't want her to lose money so I
hope at some point he does get back and
just approaches the right way before he
gets gets on the field but I just think
Seattle's proven that they're not well
they won't buckle they've proven it
through this I mean camp Chancellor he
held out a few years ago he didn't get
crap no it doesn't hurt he missed two
games and they weren't grown on defense
and he came back and week three so III
don't think that this group of Schneider
Carroll the owner I don't think they're
afraid to do this because I think they
know that they have a new game plan in
Seattle and they're moving forward they
held out for so long and then they
cashed in all those guys and I think
they immediately regretted yeah because
they weren't able to get depth one other
thing about Kyle so a camera what
reporter it was but asked 20 coaches I
think it was an mm QB asked 20 coaches
at the combine which offensive schemes
they're gonna study for 2018 every coach
named two teams and only two teams so
Kyle on the Rams Niners in the Rams
that's it yeah so no one's looking at
like the the the RPO Eagles every team
Niners yeah I mean it's the course
they're gonna be you know I would say
Sean Payton I'm sure he was in there a
lot but people I feel like they kind of
get it they know it already a little
the interesting thing is about what I
find in the NFL more than anything is
nobody gets New England's offense nobody
they don't get it
because there's been very few people
there's not a lot of people in the NFL
that run it they don't understand the
rule they don't even know what they
don't know that's what I find with a lot
of my offensive friends around the NFL a
lot of times they're just the the New
England offense is a little bit of a
mystery and it's a little harder and the
knowledge of the offense that's why I
think you've seen josh mcdaniels go to
places like Denver not explode
offensively right now right away or the
st. Louis Rams because it is such a
detailed intricate offense and you need
a year or two of guys to be in it before
it can really show its true colors his
deshaun Watson running that yeah he is
at a basic at a basic level though like
Billy O'Brien's version and the New
England offense is not the same as josh
mcdaniels no josh is Josh McDaniels have
a savant underneath him does he have a
wide receivers coach like Sean McVeigh
was back in the day or Kyle Shanahan was
Chad O'Shea was the guy that was new
rumored to be the offensive coordinator
in town he's the wide receiver coach yes
did you still there he's still there
chatty o is an army okay
I like to invest in people before they
come big right stocks and bonds yeah so
Chad O'Shea is the next guy Chad O'Shea
what about him Ryan Flores on that staff
he's the defensive linebackers coach D
next in my mind certainly yeah but Chad
O'Shea tell me about it he was difficult
I mean just because of his daily energy
first of all it's just the person I want
to evaluate first right and the person's
the same every day with great intensity
and daily energy and then to be able to
command a wide receiver room wide
receiver rooms a tough job I mean a lot
of times NFL coaches are really picked
and coached at wide receiving room
because they're better at handling you
know the interactions with people more
than actually teaching the X's and O's
because they're it's a diva position
there's personalities and they all want
the ball chatty O'Shea has a great blend
of being able to do that but also being
a tough ass he's an extension of Josh to
a degree that's awesome yes I mean he's
and he's been there and knows the way
things are supposed to be done do you
think josh is crazy man Josh locks
himself in a room like on Monday we
he gets done like okay we're done with
the previous day's game and we've
evaluated that Josh will lock his ass in
a room and forget it
like you're not gonna see Josh for six
hours and then all sudden he's gonna
come out like hot off the press and
you're gonna back what it needs to be I
got a hundred new plays and you're gonna
bet what wait so hold go migrate to and
I'm like of course he do does anyone
like everyone knows he doesn't they just
like let him do his thing
yes so he locks himself in a room and is
he looking at the next opponent's team
yeah he's going in alman already on the
next opponent so for another guy that
has his plays he's gonna look at the
opponent and go let me find their
weakness let me lock myself in a room
for six hours find their weakness and
come up with like a hundred new plays
just to attack them yeah so you could
come he could come leave that room with
zero plays from the week before yeah
that definitely could be a whole like
you're gonna have some basic carryovers
always in a like a basic game plan but
yes he's gonna come out with a whole new
plan of attack of formations and
personnel sets that he think gives them
an advantage how uncommon is that I
think New England goes to a greater
extent of doing that than anybody else
with the mixing matching of personnel
formations and overall changing of
schematics on a week to week basis
nobody's unknowing TLAs level when it
comes to that he come out and go this
play is gonna be deadly like would he
like even like would it be would come
out hot and like feeling good and when
he came out hot what usually happened
the next week man I felt like we tore
people of every week never come out kind
of like I don't know I the week that
always I will remind me in any like
insecurity knowing when ever it was when
we the 2012 season we went up to New
England to play the Seattle Seahawks the
unveiling of the Legion of boom I know
I've told that story before but this
story but that whole week that was like
one of the only times I remember being
there where everybody was like damn
they're good and damn we don't really
know how this game plan is gonna work
like it was it was a different week but
Joshua's I made and then sometimes he'd
be locked in that room and I might have
called like the wrong coverage and a
certain defense for like 20 plays in my
breakdown guys come on
I mean that's how you tuck I mean look
pull up by 71 pull it up you see the way
the corners playing there that's not
cover three and you know I'd get cops
sorry Josh I'm sorry were you really
like did you really apologize because I
only know you as the guy that walks
around the office and says what are the
[ __ ] he wants like so were you really
like I know that you were the lowest I
did 20 yeah I did not want to let down
people like Josh or the other offensive
staff is because first of all every day
was a race to get work done so if I did
go back and fix 25 things gosh damn now
I'm gonna be here till 11:30 tonight
damn it
the people that have been in that office
for as long as they have yeah it's
insane to me insane brainwash train but
like when you're winning Super Bowls
it's kind of the point does take the
edge away all right let's do a few whoa
big training camps Chris Harris jr. says
Courtland Sutton is up there with
DeAndre Hopkins and Dez Bryant in terms
of getting 50 50 balls I could see that
he was amazing I mean it his quarters
was so bad at SMU he couldn't it was may
have helped him with it I mean yeah he
had to do everything he could to get a
hand on the ball but yeah I think this
is a guy to watch out for I really do
this is like to me guy we were talking
about a better version of Kelvin
Benjamin coming out Kelvin Benjamin
knows a first rounder and he was on
Florida State and they won the national
championships sure but this guy's same
size better route runner better with the
ball in it and I'm also blown away at
every Bronco story is a player on that
team going we think we can win the Super
Bowl with a case keenum like they're
blown away by Case Keenum yeah I look at
that that by receiving corps Demaryius
Emmanuel Sanders Courtland Sutton and I
go and if you had a quarterback that can
hit him they've always been talented
I've just avoided them all the time
because it's been Brock Osweiler and
yeah I mean Demaryius at one point was a
top five receiver yes he was he was JJ
Watt on one of your personal favorites
DJ reader quote he's the best nose guard
in the league I don't know if nose
guards even make the Pro Bowl anymore
just because of how it's set up
but do you do you think he's up there I
do when they lost Whitney merciless and
JJ Watt you said man they could still
get it done cuz this DJ read or
something beast in the middle yeah he is
a true you know
nose plug right I mean to gap or Vince
Wilfork of their defense but got good
athleticism and unbelievable strength of
the point of attack you cannot move him
another Clemson just powerhouse in the
middle of that defense and they play the
truth three four so they need a guy like
that he's amazing he's one of the best
threes in the sport right now he is
truly a guy that [ __ ] the play up yes
and I am now officially on this Monday
show requesting applications for [ __ ]
the play up correspondence these here's
how this is going to work I need to
stress this you're going to have to do
it every week so if you really want this
don't just be like I want to be involved
in the podcast you guys know that we
find different ways to get people
involved in the podcast this is for
people that are really gonna watch their
team and focus on just their team and
their d-line and linebackers and people
that f the play up and we'll explain it
a little bit later but the really
Genesis is if DJ reader pushes the
center and guard back and the running
back has to take a wide turn and someone
else gets the tackle we want to shout
out DJ reader right so we're looking for
one person for every team I think the
smartest way to do it is let's start a
thread on reddit if the play up and then
everyone will kind of apply but I'm
asking don't just do it to be able to do
it we really want people that are gonna
really invest in it yeah because we want
to keep track right at the end of the
year we want to give away an award yeah
we do it's we're tired of someone like
DJ reader getting JJ Watt to the Pro
Bowl because he's taking on double teams
and no one ever knows about it yeah
where the players podcast and these are
the guys that are really fatties that
guys need love too offensive line and
defensive line yeah but the guys that
get no credit for anything anymore I
mean the games become all about
receivers DB's and quarterbacks gosh if
you don't have great ones of that how
can you win the game okay you know why
because it's easier to fit into an
Instagram yeah you're right right but
you have a team that won the Super Bowls
got a great offense and defensive line
and deep as hell there no man team
there you go say one jingles [ __ ] don't
look don't guess I can't save you last
one for wow big training camp oh there's
a wide receiver and Jack
vil that's catching the attention of the
cornerback it's my man djay charkh yeah
I told you
AJ Bowie says that man is athletic he's
got a babyface but he plays like he's 30
him and Jalen Ramsey working against
each other every practice you love that
because they were going against the best
in the game if they can do it against
Jilin you get excited it's not only him
Kiel and Cole's taking another big step
that wide receivers room is a lot of
competition I've heard that there's some
people going on other podcast saying
that the Jacksonville wide receivers
were the reason they really tucked it in
and got nervous last year the
Jacksonville wide receiving corps is
still a top ten wide receiving corps in
the NFL oh they don't have Alan Robinson
oh they lose Allen Hurns maybe they let
those guys go because Dede Westbrook was
a baller last yeah maybe they let those
guys go because Keelan Cole was making
big plays every single game no doubt
about it marques Lee played really
Marquis and I'm seven million dollars
aided and Mickens went for an 85-yard
touchdown against the Seattle Seahawks
and it's not because bortles threw him
open no it's this is where the
brilliance of Tom Coughlin and we've
talked about it I know he's an X wide
receiver coach he knows how to find
these little diamonds in the rough that
yeah and they're not mean it might not
be valued as these 12 million
dollar-a-year type receivers but they're
gonna play like it this year and you're
gonna go damn how who is this guy you
know Dante Mike Moncrief I do it DJ
shark man I mean he has a chance to be
in the conversation I think for one of
the best receivers in football he is
that type of talent he's an AJ Green ish
type of guy at LSU another one where if
you had a better quarterback and a
little better offense we would have been
going wow this guy I think the top 20
pick but because he didn't people just
look at the bottom line stats and it
goes from there so he's a guy that you
see with limitless potential
I really do I thought he was a
phenomenal route runner at 6-3 195 he
ran what four threes to what the combine
I believe I think he was the fastest
offensive player at this past year's
combine and four three four four three
four and yeah he is a punt returner and
he can make people miss after the
catching catches 5050 balls like the
film the watch
Jim was phenomenal like that's where I
wanted to go like there was a I remember
we talked about it where I was like man
there's like 30 snaps where he's wide
open for touchdowns and he either has to
stop and catch the ball for a 30-yard
game or he doesn't even get to catch the
ball at all if he gets like half of
those we're talking about a guy who like
had 1,300 yards receiving and like led
college football and receiving but the
quarterback play didn't lend to that and
will be used to this yeah he could be I
have a quote from Blake bortles that's
gonna kind of wrap up our show that I
don't I know I don't have to defend your
rankings anymore
but I just don't think people listen
sometimes and I had someone the other
day tell me Oh Blake bortles did have
that 4,500 yards season and I was like
the stats after a while are just
[ __ ]
you mean the year they were three and
thirteen blade bortles said via First
Coast News I think the positive is that
the lows aren't nearly as low as they
were they're still up and down which is
going to be when you play our defense
every day I think the floor is risen the
lows are in as bad it is 1 2 3 bad plays
compared to where there are times last
year I would go for a whole day of
having a bad practice not really feeling
good about it
I think we'll have a chance he's the
only starting quarterback that is not
measured in how good he could be it's
how much bad can he avoid I know I know
he tells you it he says he's telling
people he's no starting quarterback that
talks like this I know that's why I
that's where I'm I'm trying to drive
home the point my point with the whole
70th thing is again there's about
there's almost every quarterback in
football if they were afforded the
luxuries that Blake bortles had a pint
on this team and every week is about
managing Blake so he doesn't screw
everybody would have his numbers but
better then the team would be better so
he's been afforded this luxury because
he was the third pick of the draft and
they just don't want to end the game on
it but yes I mean all the signs and
you're in the weeds like me you can read
between the lines none of the players
ever talk like that doesn't everybody I
mean the job is great in the locker room
he's a good guy they didn't even have
modeled the knee using wins
he didn't model the new uniform so I
look at it like this though I'm gonna
take a weird stance yeah I think Blake
bortles has a good year and the reason
is that they're awesome well that's one
but two all the stuff that I'm reading
is he it's been pounded into his head
this offseason yeah we're checking it
down pal yeah we're gonna enjoy the
check downs you don't need to prove that
you're number three all of this is I'm
going to avoid the bad yeah he can be
successful yeah if he avoids the bad
right but we look at it and go how
amazing could you be if you had a
quarterback that could embrace that good
they're not maximizing their team or not
no I know they're very hard way they're
directing to win they're electing to win
a Super Ball like the two thousand
Ravens they're gonna go we're just gonna
make it 13 to 12 and we're gonna win yes
and that's yeah you know you might be
able to do it and this team has a talent
to do that but that just takes one bad
balance of the football and you don't
get it and then all sudden you go damn
we were really good why did we lose
those five games this year well because
every game was a field goal game in the
NFL it's crazy
yeah it's gonna be interesting it's
another year with a lot of pressure on
Leonard fournette to really get that
offense going and it's gonna be a lot of
pressure on that defense to score points
yeah and Nate Hackett for Nate Hackett
one last thing
this was a question from an instagramer
after this josh vendrick's interview
with Drew Brees he texted me afterwards
Hendricken said it was more proof as to
why I am NOT doing what you do I will
say I haven't listened to it you would
master 5,000 says that he is from Tuttle
Oklahoma which is the hometown of Blake
jar win' and to all of the Simmons of
left go listeners there were dozens of
you that reminded me that Blake Darwin's
not a rookie thank you I've got the
message I saw that but would master
5,000 says that Blake jar win' he
believes will have more than 30 catches
this season hmm if he does this is his
proposal I want to come on set for the
show with a plus-one if he doesn't I
will shave an eyebrow you are a lot
better at this than I am
is that worth it to you do you want to
accept this proposal from
master 5000 he'll shave an eyebrow if
Blake Jarvan catches less than 30 balls
but if he catches more he gets to come
on the set mmm with a plus-one I mean I
think that's a it's a risky proposition
by him what about for us I don't know
this guy and I don't know who is plus
one is that's very true it's very scary
insane I mean I'd like to know who is
plus one is but so you're kind of like
the Hall of Fame now this is our damn
show sorry
well we'll hijack our own show at our
own expense but do we want to see this
guy's I mean it's kind of fun we get to
watch Blake Chara and get upset if he
catches a lot of balls you looking at
the depth chart yeah yeah they really
don't have any receivers right now
no that's he's gonna get some play for
sure it'll be close are you okay with 30
do you want to raise it I don't know if
you'd be okay with that yeah I know we
want to negotiate with podcasters
already could be too unrealistic 32 I
don't want lets 30 are we really gonna
be really thinking about that you decide
man on the spot just letting me decide
30 catches or or we get a video of him
shaving off an eyebrow with a thanks
Blake Charmin maybe his eyebrows are
shaved already okay I think on the wave
oh okay I think we're doing it would
master 5000 challenge accepted okay fine
we're doing it
all right everybody keep your eye on
Blake djaro in this season because it
was your masters offseason like thing
with him I don't really remember he was
he was the unknown guy that was getting
a ton of praise that nobody was being
talked about more than Blake Charmin by
Stephen Jones Yeah right
Stephen Jones the coach and general
manager of the Cowboys guys thank you so
much as always Allen who it is
we are you yeah play the music because
we're not involved in the next thing
that's just Josh vendrick we are going
on the road tomorrow we are going to
calif
and we have big stops for our upcoming
show that's gonna be really cool shoots
we're gonna be with some Rams some
Chargers some Niners it's gonna be a
blast and we're also gonna do I think
some 30-minute pods while we're on the
road just kind of doing like some little
recaps we'll hang out in Fenwick's hotel
room and then just like give them wet
willies and make them record us would
master yes if Blake gets hurt
you're shaving I think I'm still shaving
there's no excuses you can't make the
club in the tub sorry
so guys up now here is for your
listening pleasure
it is also excuse me I forgot to tell
you guys an audio exclusive so you need
to go to iTunes and subscribe why don't
you unsubscribe and re-subscribe to
listen to the Internet like they're
cheating the numbers like I am here is
Josh vendrick with Drew Brees